[Music]  I know what makes each person different  and what makes everyone the same I'm in  love with someone who wakes up in a  different party every day always the  same age never the same person twice  every day is that learning to live in  the moment and see past the body you  just have to accept someone for who they  I something that I love so much about  the script showcase love being about not  falling in love with someone's body or  anything that's even really physical and  finite I just know that you can be  attracted to way more people than you  think  I think there's a lot of representation  in this movie okay straight all these  different manifestations of what love  and be and look like it gets to the  depth of your of your soul and what it  is really to love another being loved is  love  you